[Musica]
mai
no
caio
[Musica]
ciao
c era dietro la collina ci sta la notte
bloccare assassina in mezzo al prato c'è
una per pisciare si va dritti a casa
senza cambi di cinquant'anni questi poi
da mangiare con i partiti al mondo come
5 stelle non ancora tornati
[Musica]
a
generale l'acqua è finita ellenico è
scappato dietro la collina anche per
pisciare dentro quando viene male ai
bambini piangono indietro la collina non
ci vogliono
[Musica]
no
genera queste cinque stelle perché senso
non c'è più nessuno
il nemico è scappato e vi è battuto
battuto battute anche se fa male che
torneremo dritti a casa senza più
pensare che cinque stelle a casa non ci
vogliono andare
ahi ahi ahi ahi
vai
[Applauso]
[Musica]
signore e signori ecco a voi un ospite
eccezionale per la prima volta qui all
the things di reggio emilia
ecco a voi la bocca lista
[Musica]
la bocca liste
martin è sicura
o
[Musica]
ed ora signore e signori ecco a voi
un'altra ospite incredibile la
consonante
[Musica]
[Risate]
ed ora insieme
e a me
[Musica]
a.ol
il dott
[Musica]
ciao
no
ma
[Musica]
nord
[Applauso]
[Musica]
un po mi manca l'aria che tirava o
semplicemente l'auto bianca schiena
[Musica]
e quel l'orologio non girava stava fermo
sempre da mattina a sera
come me 2t fissava io non piango mai per
te
non farò niente di simile
no mai no no no no
sì l'ho letto un po ti penso a scanso
non mi tocchi più
solo che pensavo quanto inutile
farnetica
di stare bene quando inferno e te
togli le tue mani calde non mi abbracci
mi ripeti che so un grande mi ricordi
che rivivo in tante cose
case libri auto viaggi fogli di giornali
anche se non valgono niente per lo meno
a te
ti permetto di sognare segue
di lasciarti cammina
scusa sai non ti vorrei mai disturbare
ma vuoi dirmi come questo può finire
me lo so spiegare
io
[Musica]
la notte fonda e la luna piena
ci offrivano
non solo l'atmosfera
[Musica]
con il dettaglio e area che mi manca
se sto così la primavera ma non regge
più la scusa no no
solo che pensava conte inutile farnetica
credere di stare bene quando inverno e
di togliere tue mani calde non mi faccio
i ripeti che son grande mi ricordi che
tante cose
[Musica]
case libri auto viaggi fogli di giornale
male che anche se no
quando niente per lo meno a te
ti permetto di sole
mare
io che pensavo quanto inutile farneti
per credere di stare bene
le tue mani
le calde non mi abbraccio i miei
etiche song
mi ricordi che
in tante cose
casa ibrido viaggi follia
anche se non
ti permetto adesso
se voglio
rilasciarti camera
scusa sai non chi vorrà
mai visto il mare
e questo post
ma
questo può finire
sì
avevi come questo a finire
dallo studio della storia va ora in onda
tutto il campo minato terminato
radiocronache commenti ed
approfondimenti delle più famose
battaglie storiche in studio tito livio
[Musica]
gentile ascoltatore buon pomeriggio
siamo collegati con i principali campi
di battaglia per una giornata ricca di
incontri cruciali
diamo quindi la linea il primo
collegamento a te [ __ ] sì grazie agli
schieramenti sono contrapposti ma la
situazione è ancora di parità diverse
fino a questo momento le occasioni per
la formazione greca che ricordiamo
pratica un gioco molto offensivo
a differenza dei padroni di casa
allenati da priamo che colpiscono
prevalentemente di rimessa rimanendo
così asserragliati in difesa della
propria porta il parziale all'ottavo
anno di giuoco [ __ ] 0 grecia 0 scusa
scusa ti interrompo per un aggiornamento
da cartagine qui la partita è finita
stiamo già allo spargimento del sale
tiri capitano quindi risultato finale
roma 2 cartagine 1 con le marcature di
scipione l'africano che ha messo a segno
una splendida doppietta e il gol della
bandiera di annibale barca e ti
restituisco la linea sì qui [ __ ]
l'azione si svolgerà sul settore di
sinistra del campo c'è un'iniziativa
della formazione greca con patroclo che
converge verso il centro in cerca di un
compagno lo trova in achille ottima
l'intesa fra i due che ricordiamo sono
anche i compagni di club patroclo
achille achille ancora chi tenta una
manovra di sfondamento attenzione c'è un
fallo da dietro palo palo per patroclo
riprendiamo la linea dallo studio e ci
colleghiamo ora combatterlo dove invece
stanno per iniziare le ostilità mi
sentii batterlo batterlo regia
rieccoci e vi un giorno da batterlo la
giornata qui a serena 12 gradi sul campo
e si preannuncia uno scontro molto
acceso fra le due fazioni alla mia
sinistra alla francia capitanata da
napoleone buonaparte in tenuta rossa la
mia destra rappresentativa d'inghilterra
e procede tenuta blu e due formazioni
sono già sul terreno di gioco da qualche
minuto ecco ecco squillo di tromba la
partita è iniziata e la linea vanno
studio linea che va a [ __ ] si sono
sempre [ __ ] in questo momento c'è un
parapiglia fra gli esponenti dei due
schieramenti e una fase di gioco molto
concitata attenzione certo re a terra
ribadiamo il capitano della squadra di
casa giace in questo momento sul terreno
di gioco e vediamo che sportivamente
viene trascinato d'achille a bordo campo
mentre ricordiamo che la porta di [ __ ]
è ancora inviolata canile è nata scusa
[ __ ] cannonata di bonaparte qui a
battere la francia passa in vantaggio la
land la palla lanciata da capitano della
francia ha superato la folta barriera
degli avversari e lo stadio esplode in
un boato e la linea va a [ __ ] si chiama
mi pure [ __ ] qui la partita è molto
maschia tegola per la grecia in uno
scontro di gioco infortunato achille
all'omonimo tallone stagione finita per
lui la linea allo studio riprendiamo la
lega dallo studio a per un aggiornamento
da addis abeba si segnalano gli ennesimi
cori razzisti da parte della tifoseria
fascista nei confronti del negus per la
sua faccetta nera
ci auguriamo di non rivedere in futuro
queste scene da calcio balilla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e il cammin di nostra vita oh quante
mestiere crocevia di nostra figlia ea
cosa cela luca infascelli la divina
commedia
no c'è una fiera
[Applauso]
[Musica]
carlo
che visse a roma fi buon auguro che
cantò di quel giusto che chi al mercato
mio padre comprò miserere tv ei suoi
soldi
un vino costarmi sì o no su piani teatro
perché sei signori che pur lombardo che
in quello che disse a roma super buona
81 che cantò di quel giusto fin volta
che venne di [ __ ] molti piccoli e al
mercato
mio padre comprò beh se lo dici che sei
signore che pure lombardo che nacque
subito che mi se
lascia editrice
come dire un amico
vito
fare il padellone io ti posso indicare
seduta su morte a volte che parto e
vanguardia malvagia vedi arrivare agli
occhi di bragia ti può trasportare col
suo massimo
ecco
io
[Musica]
ascoltarlo
amnistia
fede
per sempre ma gli scherzi il caronte
passava di ogni uomo grida ma gli sta
insegnando ai vice paolo e francesca
paolo non poter suo marito ha ucciso sia
lei
per una tresca tra i metri sopra sotto
terra sotto un paio di morna io che tra
l'altro sono gay
e vero che contrappasso parliamo sesso
passiamo i sodomiti che felici vanno a
spasso un conto che con capasso i
migliori anni della nostra vita
i migliori anni della nostra vita dopo
la morte senti cosa canta il sudore
ita i migliori anni dell'anno
nostra vita contrappasso marian di
ulisse facevo fa il gradasso è andato a
fondo nella di sotto o che contrappasso
viaggio in avanscoperta ai confini del
mare non c'è neanche il segnale
dell'amica pure nessuna copertura
edilizia dacia e beatrice colpa né
logico un defunto perché chi era l'alta
marea che sono i si richiuse portandosi
via
il tempo vola
ma c'è un personaggio a studiare a
scuola è assai fa
per la sua fare
qual è il suo nome non te lo chiedo a te
[Musica]
gulino
certo
mesi
io non ho mai baciato serrami del
catering marchisio
[Applauso]
ho passato
non mettiamo
k satanas curricoli unico napoli col i
curricula queste linee del coni con i
curricula beckham
dopo santana
[Musica]
miccoli con una fune
quella riva per curricoli come
penso
[Applauso]
yahoo
grazie a te
ciao ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]